las urnas han hablado y dejan un mapa
político tremendamente complicado lo
único que parece claro es que frente a
todos los pronósticos Alberto Núñez dijo
no será presidente al menos por ahora
Pedro Sánchez una vez más se ha salido
con la suya ha conseguido lo que hace
apenas unas pocas semanas parecía
imposible haya o no repetición de
elecciones ahora es el gran favorito
para mantener la presidencia del
gobierno en España Pero qué explica Este
repentino cambio Es que acaso la derecha
no logró movilizar a sus bases En qué
consistió Y dónde ha fallado la
estrategia del candidato del partido
popular Qué puede suponer todo esto para
el país arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el partido popular ha sido la fuerza más
votada después de siete años de nuestra
última Victoria en las elecciones
generales el partido popular ha vuelto a
ganar las elecciones generales
me siento muy orgulloso pero no España
por ahora no tendrá un nuevo presidente
a estas horas es prácticamente imposible
que Alberto Núñez fijo pueda desalojar a
Sánchez de la moncloa con algo más de 11
millones 125.000 votos y 169 escaños la
suma de Pepe y vox se quedó muy cerca de
la mayoría absoluta muy cerca pero lo
suficientemente lejos de poder formar
gobierno el peso de Pedro Sánchez logró
encontrar todo pronóstico subir casi un
millón de votos lo que le permitió loque
de izquierdas aguantar el envite Chapó
por Sánchez Ha logrado lo que parecía
imposible y digo contra todo pronóstico
porque esta ha sido una de las
legislaturas más difíciles
controvertidas y polémicas de la
historia democrática de España ahora con
estos resultados se abren dos grandes
alternativas que Sánchez logra el
respaldo de bildu pnv es que Rey Venegas
junto a la abstención de Jones y la otra
y quizás la más probable es que España
vuelva a votar dentro de unos meses unas
elecciones donde la narrativa habría
cambiado por completo y donde Sánchez
sería probablemente el gran favorito si
me preguntá mi opinión personal y
evidentemente no es más que eso una
opinión personal porque nadie tiene una
bola de cristal pues diría que nos guste
más o nos guste menos y en estos
momentos con los resultados que tenemos
Sánchez será presidente otra legislatura
España se aleja así de la enorme
corriente de cambio político en toda
Europa porque hoy exceptuando a España
solo cinco de los 26 gobiernos restantes
de la Unión Europea se inclinan a la
izquierda pero ahora bien qué demonios
ha ocurrido Por qué los pronósticos
parecen haber fallado tanto por qué la
derecha o el centro derecha tiene unas
expectativas tan altas
Pues en cierto modo ya os lo hemos
contado aquí en visualpolitik Sánchez
partía de una posición muy comprometida
y no lo digo solo por el resultado
adverso en las pasadas autonómicas y
municipales sino especialmente por los
escándalos las controversias yfias
políticas que ha protagonizado la lista
es larga muy larga tan solo durante el
último año y medio podemos contar las
siguientes hazañas pero le entregó el
Sáhara Marruecos Sin dar ninguna
explicación sin contar con la oposición
sin garantías para la saharauis y sin
recibir nada a cambio además puso nombre
te la relación económica con Argelia y
perdió uno de los grandes elementos de
presión de Madrid a rabat y no el
control de la inmigración ilegal no
justifica Este cambio porque nada
garantiza que Marruecos mañana diga
donde dije digo digo Diego Pero esto es
tan solo el comienzo también le ha
echado mucha cara y ha intentado sacar
tajada de la Guerra de Ucrania Pese a
que España es uno de los países que
menos ayuda le ha dado a este país ha
impulsado cambios improvisados en el
código penal contrarios a su programa de
campaña y basados en una turbia
negociación política A lo mejor de una
partida de póker lleva a cabo indultos
que había prometido no otorgar ha
establecido un Temerario impuesto contra
las grandes fortunas un impuesto al
patrimonio que prácticamente todos los
países de Europa han desechado por sus
calamitosas consecuencias ha sacado
adelante un cambio en el modelo de
trabajadores autónomos que ocasionar
mucho pero que mucho dolor en los
próximos años ha enmarañado la reforma
del sistema de pensiones hasta anunciar
una supuesta hucha mientras el sistema
tiene un boquete enorme saco adelante
una ley la ley del sí solo sí que luego
tuvo que ser reformada pero que por el
camino supuso beneficios penitenciarios
para más de 1.100 abusadores sexuales
incluso para colmo llegó a provocar una
enorme crisis institucional atacando y
deslegitimando al tribunal
constitucional en el cual Por cierto
terminó metiendo a personas tan
independientes como un antiguo ministro
de su propio gobierno y queridos amigos
amigas seguro que nos dejamos un montón
de cosas en el tintero Y eso que
hablamos tan solo del último año y medio
de locos si miramos más atrás la lista
sería interminable
a ver por supuesto también ha tenido
logros pero lo cierto Es que Sánchez ha
ido de Escándalo en escándalo y pese a
todo ha resistido Pero eso ni siquiera
es todo tras unos años políticos
agotadores Donde ha ocurrido
prácticamente de todo lo cierto Es que
las cosas tampoco han ido para tirar
cohetes
en esta última legislatura España ha
sido uno de los países con peor
desempeño económico de toda la Unión
Europea por mucho que se empeñe Sánchez
Esto es algo incontestable entre el
último trimestre del 2019 y el primer
trimestre del 2023 el pib de España
apenas creció un
0,1%. de hecho de todos los 46 países de
la ocd España se sitúa en el puesto 44
si hablamos de la recuperación económica
post
44 de 46 y eso a pesar de que Sánchez ha
gastado a manos llenas
[Música]
y en 2019 el gasto público fue del
42,3% del pib en 2022 ya pasada la
pandemia fue del
47,8%. ha sido una de las mayores
expansiones de gasto Público de todos
los países desarrollados en euros
constantes y sonantes estamos hablando
de un incremento del gasto de más de
100.000 millones de euros cada año
lo que explica entre otras cosas la
subida de impuestos y también que la
deuda pública se haya incrementado y más
de 350.000 millones de euros es decir
que tenemos una economía dopada que pese
a ello ni mucho menos ha brillado Y para
colmo tenemos la inflación y la ciudad
de tipos dos cuestiones que no tienen
que ver estrictamente con España pero
que lógicamente han hecho mucho daño en
el bolsillo de muchas familias y pese a
todos Sánchez ha resistido hay que
reconocerlo estamos ante todo un
Depredador político ahora bien que
explique exactamente el resultado es que
acaso la derecha ha pinchado ha pinchado
fijo Como apuntan algunos pues amigos
amigas Lo cierto es que no pero para
analizar lo primero que tenemos que
tener en cuenta es su estrategia
política
Y es que veréis desde los años 90 España
ha tenido esencialmente dos grandes
partidos el partido socialista obrero
español en la izquierda moderada y el
partido Popular en la derecha moderada
sin embargo en el año 2008 el entonces
partido Popular de Mariano rajoy comenzó
un giro estratégico comenzó a intentar
transitar hacia el centro un cambio de
posicionamiento que tras el paréntesis
de Pablo casado ahora ha querido
consolidar Alberto Núñez feijó 9 de
diciembre de 2022 el PP Apuesta por
persistir en la moderación y el centro
para ganar a Sánchez Esto es algo que
por ejemplo se refleja perfectamente en
esta Luna electoral que el propio
partido popular colocó en Madrid durante
esta pasada Campaña en ella podéis ver
los colores de las diferentes
formaciones que hay en España el
objetivo de este mensaje es bastante
claro el partido popular se presenta ya
no como un partido esencialmente de
derechas sino fundamentalmente de centro
Lo que podríamos denominar como un
partido de aglomeración un partido capaz
de recoger muchos votos de los electores
más moderados y menos ideologizados por
ejemplo los votos Perdidos por ciudada y
a ver podréis tener mejor o peor opinión
de esta formación política pero si
tomamos su discurso su programa y sus
acciones de gobierno el partido popular
es hoy esencialmente un partido
socialdemócrata de Centro vale lo sé
muchos no estaréis de acuerdo y Seguro
seguro que muchos estaréis diciendo pero
Enrique qué barbaridad estás diciendo
pues para hace un momento y pensadlo
bien
el PP de hoy no es un partido
particularmente conservador apoya a los
derechos lgtbi y la legislación de
género su líder no es partidario de
restringir El aborto no es contrario ni
tiene recelos hacia la inmigración y es
un partido tremendamente europeista lo
que diga Bruselas va a misa por otra
parte tampoco es un partido
particularmente capitalista o liberal
defiende la economía de Mercado Sí pero
una economía de Mercado Social es
partidario de aliviar algo a los
impuestos pero no mucho Siempre
manteniéndolos en la escala alta a nivel
internacional no es partidario de
recortar el gasto público ni tampoco
delimitar el campo de actuación del
Estado está a favor de la de la riqueza
de los impuestos progresivos de la lucha
contra el cambio climático y durante
esta campaña su líder ha dicho que no
liberalizaría el mercado laboral y que
además apostaba por garantizar por ley
la revalorización de las pensiones
conforme al ipc no sé nos podrá gustar
más o menos pero lo cierto Es que la
Esfera internacional es difícil muy pero
que muy difícil ver al actual partido
popular como un partido de derechas el
ppp del voto para feijó a los
socialistas desencantados
consultaría Felipe González de forma
intensa si soy presidente del gobierno
no oculto que tengo una relación que se
puede considerar de amistad con los
líderes socialistas Fernández vara con
García paje con lambang con barbón o con
el ya presidente de Canarias Alberto
Núñez se dijo en declaraciones al diario
El confidencial todo esto es algo que
también podemos ver perfectamente en los
varones regionales de esta misma
formación 28 de junio de 2023 Andalucía
contará con su primera estrategia de
igualdad de trato hacia el colectivo
lgtbi juanma Moreno fin de combatir la
violencia machista y el cambio climático
incluso me vais a matar pero pensad en
la propia Isabel Díaz falso
supuestamente un verso suelto la parte
más a la derecha del PP Pues bien Más
allá de sus declaraciones Cuáles son
exactamente sus medidas políticas más
conocidas pues amigos amigas medidas
como estas 28 de marzo de 2023 hay uso
lanza un plan para triplicar las
viviendas públicas a precios asequibles
y acelerar los nuevos desarrollos el
abono transporte será gratuito para los
mayores de 65 años en Madrid y por
supuesto y sobre todo tenemos Claro está
al propio Alberto Núñez fijo
el líder del partido popular ha dirigido
durante 13 años el gobierno de Galicia y
la verdad no podemos decir que haya sido
ni particularmente conservador ni
liberal por ejemplo Bajo su presidencia
Galicia fue la primera comunidad
Autónoma en aprobar una ley contra la
discriminación sexual al tiempo que se
convirtió en una de las más voraces
fiscalmente el índice autonómico de
competitividad fiscal por ejemplo
posiciona a Galicia en la parte baja de
la tabla en la posición número 12 no son
cosas que asociaríamos a un perfil
prototípico de la derecha y luego en
campaña se dice de todo eso lo sabemos
pero lo cierto Es que fijo siempre tuvo
la fama de ser muy pero que muy pobre
Pues bien sea como sea el caso es que
está evolución hacia el centro es lo que
el conocido consultor político y ex jefe
de gabinete del propio Pedro Sánchez
Iván redondo ha definido como el intento
de regresar a 1977
de esta forma el partido popular
intentaría ocupar el espectro político
que en su día ocupó la ucd de Adolfo
Suárez una especie de partido de
aglomeración a su izquierda tendría al
psoe y a la derecha sustituyendo A la
antigua Alianza Popular que era el
propio partido popular antes de cambiar
de nombre a vox
La pregunta es ha funcionado esta
estrategia hoy muchos están diciendo que
fijó ha fracasado porque no ha logrado
movilizar La pregunta es es esto así
pues no la verdad es que no
[Música]
me explico Aunque pueda sorprenderte
este 23 de Julio la estrategia de feijo
de situarse más en el centro y dejar a
Box la derecha funcionó y este bloque
logró más de 11 millones 125.000 votos
lo que supone todo un récord el centro
derecha movilizó más que nunca Y
prácticamente está cerca de su techo si
es que no lo ha tocado ya Y es que no
olvidéis que en España el voto de la
derecha tiene a ser más fiel pero la
izquierda tiene más potencial devoto
Pues bien en estas elecciones no es que
la descafeinada campaña de fijó o sus
choques con vox hayan desmovilizado a la
derecha para nada Incluso en una
comunidad como Madrid estos dos partidos
tuvieron casi 100.000 votos más que en
las pasadas autonómicas en otras
palabras que la estrategia de
aglomeración de fijo sirvió para
optimizar el voto del centro derecha El
problema es que no le permite llegar al
centro izquierda ni tampoco desmovilizar
a sus votantes todo lo contrario este 23
de Julio a la izquierda logró una enorme
movilización el mensaje del miedo ante
la llegada de vox defendido por Sánchez
y el rechazo de muchos españoles a esta
formación política fue más que
suficiente para movilizar a más de 12
millones de votantes Este es el motivo
por el que fijo no es presidente
quizás el mayor error de los populares
es haber hecho una campaña terriblemente
descafeinada hijos se dedicó a esquivar
el mayor número de temas posibles a
tener un perfil bajo y presentarse
únicamente como alternativa al sanchismo
derogar el sanchismo en su totalidad la
drogar el salmo
y al socialismo O sea que no parece que
sea el sanchismo verdad el más indicado
para decirle el sanchismo sea eso lo que
sea el problema El problema es que la
campaña vacía del PP hizo que vox al
final fuera un tema absolutamente
principal y determinante no ha habido
nada más y al final mensajes como que te
bote chapote han conseguido Exactamente
lo contrario a su objetivo muestrales
son lo mismo han llegado ustedes hasta
incluso advertir esta maldad del que te
bote chapote que te bote chapote señor
fijo
[Aplausos]
Esto es algo que el partido socialista y
sumarán salido explotar a las mil
maravillas y es algo que ahora tanto en
el PP como en vox tendrán que
reflexionar de cara un posible adelanto
electoral unos para diseñar una campaña
más constructiva y los otros quizás para
ser menos radicales pero ahora bien No
solo el PP ha hecho una campaña vacía lo
que nos lleva directamente a la segunda
parte de este vídeo atentos
[Música]
las grandes ausencias
a ver me vais a llamar iluso pero se
supone que las campañas políticas son el
mejor escenario para hacer una
radiografía y plasmar una narrativa del
país que persigue cada partido político
esta campaña por ejemplo podría haber
sido una de las mejores problemas y
retos los hay para dar y tomar sin
embargo este no ha sido el caso Sí hemos
visto a un Pedro Sánchez ir a platos y a
medios que no visitaba desde hace años
hemos visto un fijo sacar sobresaliente
en escapismo básicamente se ha dedicado
a esquivar todas las balas y no decir
nada de nada Incluso hemos visto
planchar una vicepresidenta del gobierno
y vídeos como este
[Música]
no es una broma esta ha sido una campaña
que ha tenido dos lemas o conceptos
políticos estrella por decirlo de alguna
forma que te vote chapote y perro
Sánchez en lugar de Pedro Sánchez y la
verdad poco más y eso que España
queridos amigos es el país con más
desempleo de la ocd y el país con más
desempleo juvenil de toda Europa
hablamos de un país que ha pasado de
suponer El 1,87% del pib mundial en el
año 2005 al entorno del 1,30% en la
actualidad Pues bien nada de esto ha
tenido mucho protagonismo en campaña de
hecho podemos poner sobre la mesa tres
grandes temas que han pasado
completamente desapercibidos y que sin
embargo marcarán la agenda política de
los próximos años
[Música]
primero el tema estrella el
envejecimiento demográfico y las
pensiones ningún candidato ha planteado
ninguna reforma Más allá de seguir
revalorizándolas Pese a que las
matemáticas aquí son bastante claras no
se puede o mejor dicho hoy no conviene y
mañana no se podrá
[Música]
si para finales de los años 90 las
personas con 65 o más años suponían el
13% de toda la población hoy son ya casi
el 20% y en 2050 uno de cada tres
españoles estará en esta franja de edad
esto explica porque en 2023 el sistema
de pensiones tiene un boquete
presupuestario real de más de 40.000
millones de euros Mientras que el gasto
en pensiones se situará en unos 190.000
millones la recaudación por cotizaciones
sociales será de poco más de 150.000 y
lo peor está por llegar
pero qué más da en campaña básicamente
todos se han limitado a decir que hay
que seguir subiendo las pensiones
por supuesto tampoco se ha hablado de
incentivar el ahorro privado ni de
planes para reciclar a los trabajadores
o para extender la vida laboral Más allá
de los 67 años por ejemplo mientras que
en Nueva Zelanda el 20% de la población
mayor de 65 años trabaja en España este
porcentaje es de solo el
5%. segundo tampoco se ha dicho
prácticamente nada sobre impuestos
productividad o competitividad
[Aplausos]
Sí lo sé fijo ha prometido una
ligerísima rebaja del irpf y en la
izquierda han estado hablando de los
ricos pero de cambios cambios de verdad
nada de nada Y eso si hablamos de
impuestos lo de la productividad y la
competitividad bueno eso no se contempla
ni como suplentes y eso a pesar de que
las cosas no van bien por ejemplo en el
conocido índice de competitividad que
elabora la escuela de negocios Suiza
imed España se ha dejado en su última
edición 11 puestos respecto a 2018 y en
lo que respecta la productividad bueno
digamos que desde los años 80 la
productividad En España se ha reducido
estrepitosamente esto quiere decir que
con el mismo número de trabajadores y
máquinas Ahora somos incapaces de
producir más de lo que producíamos hace
40 años pues prácticamente ni una
palabra en tercer lugar podríamos
mencionar otro gran desaparecido la
educación Y es que veréis las últimas
evaluaciones muestran que España sigue
cayendo en los rankings Internacionales
lo que explica que veamos noticias como
estas 16 de mayo de 2023 los alumnos de
10 años de España van en lectura casi un
curso escolar por detrás de los de
Inglaterra 3 de octubre de 2022 la ocd
advierte de que el 28% de los jóvenes
españoles no tiene terminado el
bachillerato ni la fp el porcentaje más
alto de la Unión Europea y no solo eso
España también es uno de los países con
más jóvenes que ni estudian ni trabajan
Ni más ni menos que uno de cada cinco
muy por encima de la media Europea y de
la ocde
Y eso Por no hablar de la Universidad
donde menos del 40% de los estudiantes
terminan sus estudios en tiempo y luego
está el problema de la formación el
problema de la calidad y del tipo de
formación por ejemplo el porcentaje de
estudiantes que optan por carreras de
ciencias ingeniería tecnología o
matemáticas es muy bajo Pese a que hay
una enorme escasez de profesionales en
estos sectores
por supuesto todo esto son cosas que
afectan a los niveles de productividad
que veíamos antes y no no se trata de un
problema de presupuesto ni de medios por
ejemplo el gasto por estudiante teniendo
en cuenta incluso la diferencia de
precios de Estonia es más bajo que el de
España y aún así tiene el mejor sistema
educativo de toda Europa y tampoco es un
problema de profesores en España hay
10,8 millones de estudiantes y casi un
millón de profesores Esto hace que los
centros públicos hablemos de 10,4
estudiantes por profesor una cifra
bastante razonable Y sobre todo un
problema de modelo y de enfoque y de eso
la campaña Pues tampoco prácticamente
nada de nada amigos os hemos hablado de
todos estos problemas largo y tendido en
nuestro canal hermano visual económico
os dejo algunos enlaces en la
descripción pero sea como sea ya lo veis
son temas que no han aparecido en la
campaña una campaña donde todo ha sido
escoger entre acabar con el sanchismo y
frenar a vox Y si la derecha movilizado
a los suyos la izquierda también lo ha
hecho resultado fijo no será presidente
La pregunta es qué pensáis que ocurrir
ahora qué os parece el nuevo escenario
político de España amigos dejadnos
vuestras impresiones en los comentarios
y hablamos debate y ahora si este vídeo
os ha resultado interesante darle a like
y suscribiros si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho una vez más Muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]